もう10月後半か
もうすぐハロウィンですね
パーティーみたいな　ごちゃごちゃするのが嫌いです
はじめしゃちょーです！
なんかね　日本のハロウィンって
こう　みんなパーティーしたいだけみたいな
あわよくば　こうなんか
うへへ　みたいな感じがするんで
好きじゃない！
冬が近づいてまいりましたが
受験生の皆さん
真の勝負が始まる時期だと思います
最終局面ですね
自分の弱点をみつけて　勉強していくところだとおもうんですけど
たぶん　今年は出ないと思います
出ないと思うんで　たぶん　2016年バージョン
はじめしゃちょーが選ぶ
今年もね　色々出てましたね
マイナーチェンジが多かった　色違いとかね
グレードが上がったバージョンとか　色々出たんですけど
その中で僕が独断と偏見で　使いやすさもこめて　なんですけど
一番は見た目ですね　かっこいシャープペンを3本準備したので
そちらを紹介していこうと思います
勉強のやる気が出ないとか　受験で行き詰った人がいたら
シャープペンを替えてみてください
僕　高校の時のお小遣いが
受験期は毎週1本シャープペンを買っていたので
文房具替えるとモチベーション上がるんですよね
では　見ていきましょう
ブッーー
ウァアン！
こちら・・・
クルトガの赤でございます
皆さん　ご存じでしょう　クルトガですね
文字が太らない　シャープ
クルトガ・・・
このランキングかなり偏りがあるとあるので　基本的に
赤いシャープペン好きなんですよね
赤バージョンのクルトガ　あんまり見た事無かったんで
すごくカッコいいなと思いました
デザインが洗練されてるのがいいと思います
黒と赤ですね
クルトガエンジンは相変わらずオレンジです
芯が0.5㎜なんですけど　0.3㎜になる所のオレンジが
黄色になってた気がします
分かりやすいですね
実際　書いてみましょうか
ほら　中のクルトガエンジンが　ずっと回転してる
もう皆さん知ってるよね
優れた感じでございます
僕あんまり使わないんですよねクルトガ
なぜかと言うと　一瞬沈むんですよ
ほら　銀の部分
銀の部分と黒の部分　縮まるの分かりますか？
この動き
このブレが　あんま好きじゃない
ちょっと使いづらいですね
気にならない人なら　いいと思うですけど
少しだけでもブレと　それが100回ブレると
どれだけの誤差になるか
100回ブレるとね
1メートルぐらい誤差が生じてるかもしれない
1メートルも誤差があると　何文字の字が書けたかと想像すると
もったいないなって思いますね
何　言ってんの俺
自分で気持ち悪…
最近　紹介しました
こちら　スマッシュでございます
相変わらずカッコいいね　洗礼されたデザイン
手が大きくて　持ちづらいんですけど
そんな事　気になりません
カッコいいね　めちゃくちゃカッコいい
黒・赤っていいよね
本能的に　黒・赤が好きなんですよ
黒か赤で　統一したくなるタイプなんで
よく見てください　周りのモノを
召喚はしてねぇな…
このまえ紹介したんで　緩くいきます
見所は　書きやすさですね
書きやすさの面では　この右に出るもは無いんじゃないかというくらい
書きやすいんでこざいます
僕紹介してから　無くなったらしいですよね　全国のロフトから
メルカリみたら　4000円とか7000円とかで売ってて
うわっ　ヤバって思いました
・・・レアだよ
これはね　見た瞬間　惚れてしまいました
こちらぁ！
デルガードなんですけど　普通のデルガードとは違う
お洒落タイプです
もう、折れないで有名です
デルガードのタイプLXでございます
いやー　カッコよすぎでしょ
これはカッコよすぎでしょ
カッコヨスギデショ！
もう・・・ほんとに　一番好き
赤・黒だとちょっと　敵の色だから闇の心が混ざってるというかね
後ろめたい気持ちで　赤・黒使っちゃうんですけど
銀と赤　主人公カラーですよ
ウルトラマンとか銀と赤じゃん
銀と赤って　男の心をくすぐる何かがあると思うんですよ
正義的なね
ジャスティスに拘りますね
僕の中でね　書きやすさがあれば　見た目と色だと思ってます
失礼します
この感じ大好き
うぁーかっけえ　これですよ
高級感がたまらないですね　デルガード
金属のグリップですね
ここがデルガードシステムで　芯が折れなくなっております
この色合いは　最高にカッコいいですね
たまんない　たまんない
これが　僕の中では今年一番カッコいいと思ったシャープペンでした
遊戯王カードで機械族デッキつくるやつなら大抵好きですよ
こーゆー書き方しても折れないんで
筆圧強い人とか　おすすめです
うん　書きやすさも文句なしでございます
今年受験しててたら　これで受験挑んでました
見た目では文句なしで　これが一番じゃないでしょうか
はい皆さん　どうだったでしょうか
完全に僕の趣味が出てましたね
やっぱ　このデルガードのタイプLXが
ひとつ群を抜いて　カッコよかったのかと思います
こちらの2本もカッコいいです
基本的に使ってるの　全部赤・黒なんだよね
赤・黒のどれかになってるんでね
やっぱ赤・黒っていいよね
他にも　いろんなカラーバリエーションがあったんでね　是非ね…
青もあったんだ！
青も銀もあった！めっちゃカッコいい！
なんと自己満な動画だ
俺は楽しかったぞ
勉強のやる気がでないとき　是非シャープペンを替えてみてください
受験戦士における　かけがえのない武器
それがシャープペンです
己のシャープペンを信じ　受験戦争を勝ち抜いてください
何　言ってんだ俺